tom felton thought harry made a big  mistake rejecting his offer i think i  can tell the wrong sort for myself  thanks wrong answer harry  [Music]  you just missed out on a serious  opportunity all the students reactions  to the great hall were genuine we've  never seen the great hall ever  this was our first actual look at it so  everyone looking around going oh my gaze  that was real tom wasn't the only felton  to appear on screen oh my days that is  my grandfather that's what i forgot my  grandfather my real grandfather is in  this not him he's not dumbledore the  sorting head did have a voice on set  you'd have a guy on set and did the  voice it's helpful because the hat  wasn't that animated on the day it was  quite hard